okay nate thank you much it is 603.
we're following some breaking news right
now metro police investigating a double
murder near the strat two people killed
hecker mejia live this morning near
chicago and industrial with the latest
details hector
hey there john we're in a neighborhood
just north of the strat where right
behind me you see the police response
right at the corner of chicago and
fairfield just for some perspective
they are along chicago right between
industrial and las vegas boulevard
as you can see live right now several
cruisers kind of swapping out shifts
and they've been here for quite some
time metro police confirmed they are
investigating a double homicide
that is all of the information we have
right now though i walked up to one of
the officers out here they told me their
watch commander
and that the homicide unit are not
available on the scene to provide
additional information
but from what we can tell here along the
street we have several investigators
here
along chicago taking pictures this is
where they tell us they're investigating
the
the double homicide and also in one of
these vehicles there's one person who
appears to be detained
we do not know if they are arrested or
not we just see them detained inside the
cruiser but again
this is the scene of the double homicide
investigation just north of the strat
right at chicago and fairfield
just off the las vegas strip we're
working to get more details for now
we're going to send it back over to you
guys